dedicó su vida a la lucha por la
democracia aunque después de su tercera
reelección tras modificar la
constitución a sus 83 años alpha condé
se enfrenta a las críticas de la
oposición y también a las de sus
antiguos compañeros de lucha en 2010
alpha condé fue el primer presidente
elegido democráticamente en guinea para
más tarde ser reelegido en 2015 y en
2020 no obstante para muchos sigue
siendo el hombre que puso fin a 52 años
de dictadura en guinea
la llegada de alpha condé trajo
esperanza por la forma en la que llegó
al poder es decir a través de las urnas
tenemos una oposición que es capaz de
cuestionar y debatir sobre las acciones
del gobierno
sin embargo la ong amnistía
internacional es mucho más dura con el
balance de alpha condé y denuncia una
feroz represión de la oposición
especialmente en las manifestaciones el
año pasado se modificó la constitución
tras un referéndum y se decidió mantener
el límite de dos mandatos presidenciales
pero con d dijo que esta modificación
reiniciaba la cuenta y le permitía
presentarse dos veces más con fuertes
impugnaciones en su contra donde
consiguió ser reelegido en octubre de
2020 tras obtener el 59.5 por ciento de
los votos en la primera vuelta